I talked to these young guys now I'm
trying to with I'm trying to have a 22
year old guys right now I got Scar
Tissue older than a lot of these guys
I'm 36 years old you know and I just say
hey man don't think about you today
let's think about let's think about you
10 years from now you want to be where
I'm at 36 years old still doing what I'm
doing and I made a career and I'm able
to be able to take care of my family so
so with that going back to college
tyron's a you know he's not even to me
in in the sport of of wrestling mixed
martial arts I don't think you're a true
man until 30. that's that's my true
belief that's when I truly finally felt
like a man and maybe I'm a late bloomer
tyron's you know 22 at that time I'm 18.
he's got the Big Brother on me so I
wasn't going to beat him and he was much
bigger and I was a scrawny little
freshman but I started obviously to hold
my own a little bit more here and there
but it just takes time as well it takes
time in business your first your first
entrepreneurial Adventure compared to
your 50 you're just a different person
you're a galvanized by the fires that
you have put yourself through in
business in relationships and for me it
was obviously physical